es uno de los mayores fracasos para la
salud pública de reino unido los
primeros casos de kobe 19 aparecieron en
reino unido en enero de 2020 pero hasta
el 23 de marzo no se ordenó un
confinamiento a nivel nacional ahora un
nuevo informe condenatorio dice que la
medida llegó demasiado tarde
francis
a partir de esta tarde debo dar al
pueblo británico una instrucción muy
simple deben quedarse en casa porque lo
más importante es evitar que la
enfermedad se propague entre los hogares
de turín falso las conclusiones de una
investigación parlamentaria muestran que
el gobierno británico esperó demasiado
tiempo para ordenar el confinamiento lo
que provocó miles de muertes
innecesarias
retrasando deliberadamente la aplicación
de la restricción en una estrategia para
lograr la inmunidad de rebaño el informe
de 150 páginas se basa en el testimonio
de 50 personas entre ellos el ex
secretario de salud mat bangkok a pesar
de que el reino unido fue uno de los
primeros países del mundo en desarrollar
una prueba de kobe en enero de 2020 el
informe muestra que durante el primer
año de la pandemia el sistema de test y
rastreo no tuvo éxito sin embargo el
comité alabó el temprano enfoque del
gobierno en las vacunas como la salida
definitiva de la crisis sanitaria
actualmente el 80% de las personas
de 12 años en reino unido están
vacunadas y el próximo año se espera una
investigación pública completa sobre la
gestión de la crisis del hobbit 19 en el
país